best joke about the baby for nirvana
suing nirvana you heard about this the
baby from the never mind album is suing
um the nirvana estate for like uh you
know child exploitation or something
they call it child pornography so
whatever how did you explain that i
thought the baby was doing a collab with
nirvana that's a story
in the vid in the cover of that it's a
baby yeah really there's a nirvana
outcast now you this is iconic there's a
little kid in a pool like yo if you're
in the pool put your lighters on i don't
even know who nirvana is shut up you
know nirvana i probably have heard a
song i cannot identify them yeah you
know it's a band so they their first uh
maybe their second album but their big
album is a baby and a boy they killed
himself was he part of that yes yes
he split no he died while he was in he
died while he was leading oh okay
they're big album covers a baby in a
pool naked chasing dolls only [ __ ]
white [ __ ] don't know
[ __ ] so you think you think my [ __ ]
don't know honestly
i [ __ ] different type of [ __ ] baby
every type of white [ __ ] yes and they
all know that they're probably not al is
black dude he doesn't know anything
about white stuff exactly or black stuff
yeah i'm puerto rican i finished
explaining anyway there's a baby on the
cover baby's on the cover naked and he's
chasing like a dollar bill on like a
fishing pole fishing hook or whatever
but it's this iconic cover there's a
dollar floating in the pool he's in the
pool the shot is under the water and
he's like reaching for the dollar okay
right but you see the baby's like butt
naked yeah so now he's suing nirvana
for uh child exploitation like the
estate and uh
but the the yeah you see that never seen
that in my life that's stopped swear to
god there's no way swear to go hilarious
uh everybody else who's listening that
knows exactly what we're talking about i
apologize for wasting your [ __ ] time
there's uh matt balinski had this joke
that was really funny he goes uh that
baby's still chasing the dollar yeah
yeah yeah i thought that was the best
joke yeah right it's like he's still
trying to yeah he's still trying to get
that money um you were a hater dude i
just shouldn't sue his mom
yeah technically like his mom sold the
picture yeah his mom
exploited the baby i guess they were
also explaining the baby with with the
permission of the mom yes mom doesn't
have any money
and here's what here's what bothers me
is i think the guy has done appearances
i'm looking through the article but i
saw a thing that said like he's done
appearances as the baby he's made money
off of being that baby he's done dozens
of recreations of the and now you want
to sue because you're like yeah but i
guess it was weird it was weird that
stimulus running out bro yeah
it's also weird that you did it for
money like get a [ __ ] job bro yeah
yeah
that's weird i mean it's it's sucks such
a dangling it's all like on display but
it's like your baby dancing yeah it's
your baby dang you don't know what they
grew into like yeah i bet you got a hug
i'm totally fine with my baby dangling
being shown it's long yeah
yeah yours you sure yeah my baby
dangling like whatever i don't i put a
baby dangling picture up
i put i put a baby dangling picture of
my kids all right that's great
i would of your own kids
i posted bangalore baby dangling
i put on the story nah maybe not a post
i put on the story and i was gonna live
forever bro say what that's gonna lift
up put on the story 24 hours with a
swipe up yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you